blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman we have so much to talk
about today so let's get right into it
last night was a special primary
election in Ohio's 11th District and it
has ended up as a major major
disappointment for the activists left
I'm going to give you my analysis uh
first we will look at the results and
unfortunately I'm reading a lot of what
I think are I would just call them
overly dramatic analyzes about this race
from some on the left so I'll give you
my sense of what I think happened in a
moment let's first look at the results
again this was the Ohio special election
primary the 11th Congressional District
Democratic primary
this was an election to replace Marsha
fudge who joined Joe Biden's cabinet now
the establishment candidate the the
candidate anointed by The Establishment
Democratic party was Chantal Brown there
were hopes that activist Nina Turner
would uh come out ahead and it did not
go that way as of this moment the
results were last updated or very early
this morning so nothing's changed for
some time Chantal Brown coming out ahead
of Nina Turner by about six points just
a hair under six points only about 4 200
votes separating the two remember this
was a Democratic Primary in the 11th
congressional district so a relatively
small
um electorate so those are the results
and
um I want to give you my analysis of
what took place but first I want to talk
about some analyzes that I think are
just missing the Mark here there are
narratives being pushed about what
happened here in certain circles that
just don't make sense to me I'm not
against these being possible analyzes
but when I look at them they don't make
sense one is this was a racist thing
against Nina Turner now if you look you
would notice that Chantal Brown Nina
Turner's opponent who won is also black
so it just being racism which I've seen
a couple of of hot takes just doesn't
make sense to me so then when you dig
deeper some people will say well what we
mean by that is Chantal Brown is not as
black as Nina Turner in a lot of ways
that's a really weird argument to hear
people on the left making it sounds sort
of colorist to me and I understand what
what they may mean by that is that Nina
Turner has more issues of particular
concern to the black community as part
of her platform than Chantal brown but
to say Chantal Brown is not really as
black as Nina Turner that's a very weird
thing I can't get behind that
um so then it gets to well Chantal Brown
had significantly more white supporters
that's what we mean uh whites who didn't
vote for Nina because she's black but
they voted for Chantal Brown despite
Chantal Brown being black that's really
weird to me and again most of the
district is black this is a primarily
it's like 53 we'll look at the numbers
and it's like 54 black District that's
that's a strange thing to say to me uh
that that doesn't really make sense so
then another one I'm seeing
is that Israel picked Chantal Brown and
Israel funded Chantal Brown because Nina
Nina Turner is a four Palestinian rights
um this one's also kind of weird and you
know there aren't that many Jews in that
District it's a mostly black District 54
some of the of the white voters uh are
Jewish and some of them are Democrats
and some of them voted in the Democratic
primary so I think what they're getting
at is that a group called The Democratic
majority for Israel
supported Brown over Nina Turner and
that's true now there's the perception
rightly or wrongly that Nina Turner is
is like against Israel's existence I've
not seen evidence of that and Nina
Turner has denied that Nina Turner also
came out against the BDS movement but
she's also against legislation to curb
BDS Nina Turner said she's okay with
military aid to Israel but wants it to
be conditional she tweeted and departed
during the last flare-up and that's a
that's a controversial term when it
comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict we don't have to adjudicate it
and you it's it's just it's
controversial in in some circles so the
the truth is that that group did support
Chantal Brown that's accurate now to go
further and say this has Israel's hands
all over it starts to get conspiratorial
and it borders on an anti-semitic Trope
this particular group which is an
American group
supported Chantal Brown that's true
um to say Israel picked Chantal Brown
over Nina Turner starts to get a little
bit anti-semitic so what do I really
think happened I think that the the
explanation here is really boring I
think Ohio democrats are mostly
relatively okay with bidenism for now
now you might say they wrongly think
bidenism is good for them that that's
okay you could you can make that
argument but as far as they're concerned
I think they're more or less okay with
bidenism right now and they pick the
candidate that's sort of more in line
with bidenism I really think it's that
simple this is a district that's mostly
black mostly working class without
college degrees median household income
of 42 000 that's well below the national
median
and they're just sort of okay with a
more moderate approach it is Ohio after
all now one other thing there are claims
that uh Brown went negative with lies
against Nina Turner but that actually
there was some of that on both sides
there was an Nina Turner ad in the final
days of the race which claimed that uh
Chantal Brown is under an Ethics
investigation which was asserted without
evidence now that there may be an
investigation but there was mudslinging
on both sides so to me this is not this
incredible Crossing the Rubicon Black
Swan type of event it's really similar
to Bernie versus Biden I would like the
Democratic party to be more Progressive
than the average voter actually is if
you looked on Reddit and Twitter it
seemed like Bernie had a lot more
support than he ultimately did
likewise if you looked on Reddit and
Twitter it looked like Nina Turner had a
lot more support than she actually did
Turner did pretty well she lost by six
in the end right now this Ohio district
is relatively happy with a Biden sword
of democrat and they elected someone
along those lines I think it's that
simple and I'm glad to have my mind
changed if folks disagree all right very
big news yesterday and we have to give
praise to congresswoman Corey Bush for
really pushing for this this I would
call this a progressive victory of sorts
even though it may be struck down by the
Supreme Court relatively quickly the CDC
has extended the eviction moratorium we
talked about this last week we talked
about this a bunch of times because it's
a really important issue the CDC has
issued a new eviction ban based on the
pandemic effective through October 3rd
the former moratorium expired last month
as we covered there were 11 million
Americans behind on rent as the Delta
variant surges this will be targeted at
areas of the country experiencing high
levels of infection from coronavirus it
will last 60 days until October 3rd and
the protection could cover around 90
percent of renters now this may be
struck down and I think that you know
I'm giving you both sides of it this is
really a progressive Victory and Cory
Bush deserves a lot of credit she was
instrumental in pushing this to happen
at the same time
there is a big Supreme Court threat uh
that this um will not hold the um there
is a Politico article which calls it a
potential clash with the Supreme Court
and what's at issue here is whether the
CDC uh really has the authority to do
this and it may well uh the answer that
the Supreme Court comes up with maybe no
Joe Biden yesterday said he went to
constitutional Scholars to find out
about the cdc's legal Authority and what
they do that is most likely to pass
muster constitutionally and Biden said
the bulk of the scholarship suggested
this would not pass muster in the courts
but there were some Scholars that said
it could
this targeted moratorium comes after the
White House insisted for days that the
CDC doesn't have the authority to act
and that Congress must pass an extension
the house has left for a multi-wick week
recess after failing to pass an
extension with Pelosi and other top
Democrats furious at the White House for
putting this at their feet so bottom
line this may not hold
um it appears as though the opinion of
the Supreme Court is that the CDC cannot
do an eviction moratorium that it must
come from Congress and Congress is out
of session let's hope that's not the way
it goes down but I think we have to be
prepared for the reality that it may of
course this is an absolutely crucial
thing to do there are people who even in
normal non-pandemic situations can't
afford an unexpected 400 expense
something like half the country can't so
if you have two three four five even
more months of rent stacking up and all
of a sudden the protection against
getting evicted goes away you were at
real risk of getting evicted now what
just one other thing
I don't believe that the nearly the 11
million or even eight or nine million
would actually get evicted there are
things taking place at the state level
there are other programs that are
available to some of these people so the
the number really at risk of getting
evicted like in the next month was
nowhere near the 11 million it doesn't
change the importance and significance
of doing this and now we have to see if
it will hold up in court let me know
your thoughts you can find me on Twitter
at dpacman remember that Monday August
16th is the 16th anniversary of the show
and we'll be doing a big membership
special if you'd like to be notified
about it with instructions on how to
take advantage again on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist then what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich Yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes I
recently read A Brief History of Time Of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction category stories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpackman I've put the link right
underneath this video
so many things happening from the
standpoint of vaccine requirements and
mandates the big news yesterday is that
New York City will be mandating vaccines
if you want to go to restaurants if you
want to go to gyms and if you want to go
to most indoor entertainment type venues
New York City Mayor Bill de Blasio
mandating coveted vaccines for certain
indoor activities the order goes into
effect August 16th with full enforcement
starting September 13th de Blasio says
the Mandate known as the key to NYC pass
would encourage increased immunizations
to combat the spread of the Delta
coronavirus variant the mayor's order
comes a day after de Blasio mandated
vaccinations for all of the city's new
hires de Blasio added the city will
begin inspecting businesses for
compliance in mid-september all affected
customers and workers can either provide
their vaccination cards or upload proof
of vaccination to the Excelsior pass
application New York City is thought to
be the first in the nation to implement
such a mandate Joe Biden responded
affirmatively when asked at a press
conference yesterday if he believed
other cities should follow suit but
stakeholders across the food industry
raise concerns about how the program
will work they are overwhelmingly
concerned about
they're saying listen this is not like
checking an ID to make sure someone's
really 21 before you serve them alcohol
this is much more invasive it's going to
really affect restaurants but needless
to say de Blasio is going forward with
it I believe it will encourage more
people to get vaccinated here is uh Bill
de Blasio
talking about this yesterday during a
press conference this is crucial because
we know that this will encourage a lot
more vaccination we've seen it already
we've seen the impact of the Mandate
we've put in place for city workers
already starting to move people to
vaccination we've obviously seen the
positive impact of incentive as well
the goal here is to convince everyone
that this is the time of going to stop
the Delta variant the time is now and
that means getting vaccinated right now
this new policy will be phased in over
the coming weeks
so we've been working with the business
Community getting input we're going to
do more over the next few weeks the
final details of the policy will be
announced and implemented in the week of
August 16th okay so without question
this is happening the question the
questions are how is it going to be
implemented and how is it going to be
enforced uh New York Times also writing
New York City will require workers and
customers to show proof of at least one
dose for indoor dining and other
activities we are seeing other examples
of this as well a growing number of Los
Angeles restaurants and bars are
themselves requiring proof of covid-19
vaccination
Microsoft will require proof of
vaccination to enter their buildings in
the United States the full opening of
its offices will be no earlier than
October 4th so they've got a couple of
months Tyson Foods will be mandating
vaccines for its U.S Workforce we know
that food processing plants were big
points of spread relatively early in the
pandemic so this is happening the
questions are how will the enforcement
work and I know a lot of you have been
emailing me saying David you know it's
really easy to forge vaccine cards it's
not only easy theoretically it's already
happening we already are aware of all
sorts of stories of people having and
presenting fake vaccine cards so there's
no doubt that it will happen to some
degree but the point here is you know
you you put a welfare a social insurance
system in place there will be some
people who misuse it but does it do good
at the macro level you put something
like this in place well some people lie
and about being vaccinated and get away
with it yes but they're already not
vaccinated if you incentivize a bunch of
people to go and do it we are slowing
the spread and hopefully getting beyond
the pandemic so it's happening
we will see how it all rolls out and
there is no doubt that you will continue
to see protests and more uh there are
some who are calling this nazi-like and
we will get to that a little bit later
continuing our uh sort of tour of the
news here
um it is now time for New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo to resign Uh I that that is
my view Joe Biden said the same
yesterday and many others as well
um he has been
um uh now accused and investigated for
uh sexually harassing multiple women
we now have the results of an
investigation CNBC summarizes it New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo sexually
harassed multiple women who worked for
the state and elsewhere according to a
report by State Attorney General Leticia
James the investigation concluded Cuomo
quote violated federal and state law
James said at a press conference Cuomo
then retaliated against a former
employee who complained publicly about
his conduct according to the report the
probe into numerous women's allegations
of sexual harassment by Cuomo started in
March after the state's executive
chamber granted James's request to
investigate
further coverage of this Albany D.A
criminally investigating Cuomo asks any
victim of New York governor sexual
harassment to contact office the D.A of
Albany County said his office is
criminally investigating Cuomo
D.A David Soares said his office would
welcome any victim to contact our office
with additional information about Cuomo
source that he plans to request
investigative materials from the state
attorney general's probe of the alleged
harassment of 11 women so listen for
people who were saying oh David you
partisan shill and you'll bump up no
hold on guys we're going to have the
same standard here for left and right
earlier there were allegations and an
investigation started and at that time I
said let's see what the investigation
finds we now have an investigation that
appears to have been done without
obvious political bias of some kind
where the investigation's results would
not be trustworthy so although there
have not been criminal charges here the
investigation is credible and this in my
view now encumbers Andrew Cuomo's
ability to just be the governor to such
a degree that I believe it is time for
him to resign
um that I I don't find myself even
needing to say much more about it it's
just time for him to resign now
interestingly
um he put out an an 85 85 page written
response there's only 26 pages of text
and a lot of the pages are just pictures
of Andrew Cuomo and various types of
embrace with different figures including
Joe Biden
um with his mom Matilda Cuomo with
hurricane victim Sandra Patterson it's
basically uh oh I'm sorry this is an
example of George W bush embracing
hurricane victim Sandra Patterson sort
of saying listen this type of hugging is
not a big deal lots of people do it
here's Barack Obama hugging Hillary
Clinton it's really just not a big deal
also taking the approach in a video that
he put out
of just saying this is how I interact
with people I just hug people there's
nothing inappropriate about it which is
it's sort of like an affirmative defense
he's not denying the contact with the
women he's just saying this is no big
deal
I do it with everyone right black and
white
Young
and old
straight to an lgbtq
powerful people
friends
strangers people who I meet on the
street
so I think it's an interesting approach
I don't think Andrew Cuomo survives this
and he should resign at this time if you
disagree with me let me know I would
love to hear from you
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right today we're going to be
speaking with Mike Lindell Mike Lindell
will be a familiar face and name to many
in our audience CEO and inventor of my
pillow uh Mike I really appreciate the
opportunity to chat with you today
thanks for having me on of course so
listen you first came to my attention I
first became aware of you at the start
of the pandemic Donald Trump held this
event at the White House and announced
here are some business people that are
going to be doing things to help us you
were going to be if I recall correctly
making masks and maybe even some other
things how did you first come to to meet
Donald Trump and that relationship start
well it was the summer of 2016. uh he
invited me to Trump Tower I was August
15
2016. it was a private meeting I went in
there it was about 35 minutes just him
and I and I walked out of there and I
didn't you know I didn't I come from a
past of addiction and stuff I didn't
think politics affected any but I did
walk out of his office said he's going
to be the greatest president ever if
he's if he's with all the things we
talked about we talked about you know my
pillow being made in the USA we talked
about I said I was going to have a a
platform which I do in the
lindellrecovery network dot org which
helps addicts and he said I'm going to
stop the drugs pouring in and we we just
had this back and forth and I went to my
uh went to his employees afterwards and
I I asked them I kind of did my due
diligence I'm going is this real I mean
the only agenda he had was to help our
country and and to help people and
that's what I and they all said yes he's
amazing boss amazing man and and they
all had a personal story about them and
then boy I got back to Minnesota and I
did a press release and you didn't think
I shot someone they attacked me and
called me a racist and called me
everything and all I did was say I had a
meeting with uh with Donald Trump that
was running for president you uh at that
event at the White House that I
mentioned at the start of the pandemic
you you said that Donald Trump was quote
chosen by God how how did God reveal to
you that that he had chosen Trump
well I was a bunch of divine
appointments for me I had a dream in the
spring of 2015 that I'd be meeting
Donald Trump and I'm going why would I
want to meet Donald Trump and all of a
sudden he comes down the escalator
running for president then ahead if you
in my book I explain all this I I
actually to the National Prayer
Breakfast in early
2016 and when Ben Carson was still
running for office and I was picked out
of 12 people out of the whole prayer
breakfast with thousands there to pray
to with Ben Carson in a room and um just
these things kept happening to me and it
was the building up and I'm going this
all has to mean something and uh it
wouldn't mean that I just end up going
golfing with Donald Trump or something
and uh like there was so many Divine
appointments that led up to that and
then uh I just uh it was something
different something that you know
because I had met him I just know this
had all these things that happened I
look at the tonight know that God exists
I use mathematics and say if you have a
one in a million happen or a one in a
billion or this thing or this thing
happens that could never happen when you
add them together and consider a miracle
and that's what kept happening to me and
I'm going I go this he's been picked
he's been chosen for such a time as this
wow so if I hear you correctly you're
saying what others might see as odds and
probability you see as Divine
appointment
especially when there's more than one
and then there's confirmations of that
wow you know here's a guy for me being
just an ex-addict from Minnesota a guy
very functioning at it girl you know
growing up again uh and here I end up in
the I end up in the white house I'll
tell you an example so I end up in the
white house uh at a round table event I
never thought it could come within a
hundred yards of the White House with my
past I see I see I see I see and here I
here I end up in the White House I said
who's sitting here and they go the
president is there's like 15 of us in
the room first time I was under the
White House and and uh they do that we
go on national TV then it's just him and
I facing forward and uh it went viral
that that screenshot and all my friends
are going what is this x crack addict
sitting next to the president United
States Jesus is real because this could
not happen this makes no sense right in
other words it's almost like
Mike Lindell pillow guy being at the
White House makes such little sense it
must be divine intervention
absolutely absolutely
it's just like when I spoke at the Rose
Garden there when we when I had went
there uh uh and we did start making Mass
we had gotta I had got a uh a letter
from the White House saying would you
come in and uh because we had started
making masks we were one of the first
ones I believe in the country and we get
there and he's going to have us all
speak from the Rose Garden and you have
to have pre
pre-approved remarks and if I told you
the whole story I mean it's just uh it's
divine how everything went down even
sitting in the front row right was
things that couldn't happen that was a a
series of events happened there where I
ended up being the only one on stage
with him and then asked him if I could
say something off the cuff and flip this
paper over and then spoke out about I
remember I was getting back in the word
and and it uh if you know if you think
there I mean I was that was hurt around
the world I did 109 interviews in seven
in five days well Mike listen there's so
many things I want to ask you about let
me do a few that are sort of like
shorter things one is
um in terms of states that were given to
Joe Biden that you believe Donald Trump
won what what is the how extensive is
that list it's huge and we and it's
absolutely huge and not that I believe I
know he won I because we have all the
packet captures and the data from the
whole election we'll get to that
Minnesota to New Hampshire
um
um all the swing States we talk about
Nevada
um Georgia Michigan Wisconsin
um Arizona Pennsylvania wow I mean it
the list goes on and on it's uh there
are very few that buy more less than ten
you at one point I heard you say you
believe Trump even won California do you
still believe that that that's that's
correct and we're going to reveal that
at the Cyber Symposium I'm happy and
these are going to be we actually will
have the data to back that up what's the
math of just to pick one Mike for people
to understand California has 22 million
registered voters 10 million are
Democrats and there's 5 million
Republicans how did Trump win California
I didn't say one for sure we're going to
reveal that the supposed let's use
Minnesota okay uh my home state well
they are here they are losing Minnesota
by a hundred thousand votes now I went
around all over everyone say oh
Minneapolis and all we only had like two
big cities Duluth and Minneapolis St
Paul and it's all Democrats supposedly
right and all our Northern Minnesota
Democrats well that's that's the past
everybody that Democrat that ship sailed
those were traditional Democrats a lot
of them and Minnesota the actual number
Minnesota won Donald Trump won by 65
000. and we will show this too at this
Symposium yeah this is facts these are
facts and how did that happen because uh
it doesn't matter where you the the past
everything changed with Donald Trump
people people are voting I believe
people are voting for they want
politicians that are for the people that
think you know and Donald Trump did
stuff for all people if you get to our
great this great place we were in in
December of 2019 I think everyone
whether you're a Democrat or Republican
realizes that those those that that
month that was a manifestation of a of a
couple years of decisions being made by
politicians I.E Donald Trump and that by
me and those Common Sense decisions that
made here's a problem here's a solution
how would help people all people not
just their party or a Personal Agenda
and that's what and we've seen that we
that was it was just awesome that
everyone in this country got to
experience that what what political
decisions could could manifest to and
man everything was great there we had
Kaya's consumer confidence lowest gas
prices lowest
um unemployed unemployment I mean the
list goes on and on yeah stock market I
mean across the board those were because
of political decisions everybody I I
want to focus in on the election piece
just so we we kind of keep to keep that
path forward there are some like
Marjorie Taylor Greene who while she
believes there were problems with the
election she says Trump is not coming
back he it is false hope to believe he
will be reinstated you've said August or
September do you still believe that in
what's the mechanism
a hundred percent I believe that yeah
she's just she's misconstrued I mean
they all these this is uh here's there's
a couple things here
um we're having the Cyber Symposium
after that that's August 10th 11th and
12th everybody's gonna watch this it's I
want it to be the biggest watched event
in history yep billion people you watch
that and you're gonna see the packet
captures and data from the whole
election this is non-subjective evidence
everybody it's what I've had for months
now and I've been trying to get the word
out but I keep let's just cancel Mike
Lindell and my pillow I've been trying
to get the word out now this gets out
we've had it ready for the Supreme Court
it's called a quo warranto we bring that
to the Supreme Court and everyone says
well they're not going to bring back
Donald Trump yes they are here's why so
hold on Mike I wanna I wanna hear it but
I want to make sure the audience doesn't
miss it the Supreme Court is the
mechanism that will bring them back
you're saying there's there's more than
one but I'm giving you the first one
okay okay it's the easiest one okay okay
the easiest one this when we get through
the Cyber Symposium which everybody
needs to tell everybody to watch this is
so important because these nine Supreme
Court Justices they're people too
they've lived the American dream they
have families they have children
grandchildren friends family they need
to everyone everyone needs to watch this
because it shows that this was an attack
by China on our country it doesn't
matter if you're a Democrat or
Republican I said on Jimmy Kimmel I said
Jimmy said if it was reverse Mike would
you do the same thing absolutely I would
this is an attacker in a country so what
happens is in our country's history
every elected official everyone that you
find out later there was a crime
committed I.E election fraud the real
winner gets put back in it's happened
every single election now that's never
happened at the presidential level right
that's the only difference so there is
precedence but also you you combine this
with this is an attack by China this was
a very very very uh it's a it's an act
of War basically as well they've
attacked us and the Democrats warned us
of this everybody they warned us from my
senator Amy Klobuchar to Kamala Harris
they all warned us about this Cyber
attack about going through the machines
and taking our country without guns and
they just happened to use the Democrat
Party so no matter who you are we go
back to it now the the Supreme Court's
going to get this yeah uh we're going to
give up probably late August and now
what they do with it I'm not the Supreme
Court but they'll have some options they
might put you know pull it down and put
Donald Trump in right away because it's
evidences non-subjective I see or or
because all the down tickets were
affected too many many down tickets
maybe the Supreme Court I'm just putting
it out there has a whole new election
wow well how could we have a new
election right with these with these
machines we can't but at the Symposium
on the 10th 11th and 12th of August
members live streamed on Frank speech
worldwide of course and worldwide
prankspeech.com we're going to live
stream at 72 hours straight we're going
to unveil a replacement for the machines
and Evelyn says well Mike are you going
to do that now you're going to show this
is just a money thing so you can make
money no we're giving the technology
away to all companies okay okay but so
to one I want to go one thing because
there's so much here my head is
literally spinning here Mike
um just to show how confident you are
that this reinstatement would happen
would you want to make a financial bet
with me on it because I just don't see
it and I want to prove to people just
how confident you are would you want to
put twenty five thousand dollars up
against me on it that by the end of
September Trump is reinstated one of my
addictions was gambling ah but not but I
will tell you this I put up five million
dollars a prize yeah cyber Symposium
five million dollars for anyone that's
there which is we've invited now we have
over a hundred cyber cyber forensic
experts from around the country and a
couple from out of the out of this
country what is that what does that mean
a cyber friend what's that credential a
cyber forensic they have c-i-s-sp but
it's more than that these are these are
guys that protect our country a lot of
them work for the government that when
you have a Cyber attack these are
experts that can read these packet
captures that can just you know what
actually happened the uh you know it
shows where the attack came from the
computer that was intruded how many
votes were flipped they're going to read
all this during the 72 hours we're going
to go through all 50 states and a pack
could capture everybody is like a
picture you can't change you can't all
that's true but Mike and this is so
important because I've looked I saw the
packet captures and I saw the the
numbers and I went to in preparation for
the interview to be thorough I went to
some cyber experts on this what they
told me is that what you previewed I
don't remember if it was on Frank's
speech or on Newsmax or where it was a
couple weeks ago but you showed the
numbers scrolling they said that that's
absolutely meaningless that those are
called hex dumps and it's just a way to
look at computer memory right we just
put b-roll out there those aren't the
captures so we put b-roll those are from
the election those are
every single outlet including CNN I just
did a two and a half hour interview with
them about four days ago okay that's to
show
what this data if you're any kind of a
cyber guy you can decipher and say well
that was from the 2020 election okay I
should have told you that so what you're
saying is what you put up there is the
style of what you will be unveiling at
the Symposium but it is not the actual
data and those were actual data it was
actual data that was actual data 100
actual data so if you talk to guys that
wasn't now that wasn't packet capture
that was data from the packet captures
that were captured so what we're going
to do at the Cyber Symposium you're
going to be able to go up to imagine
this we're going to have on stage we're
going to have a panel and we're going to
go just like election night in the state
of New Hampshire goes to Donald Trump
whoa this will be the real election okay
to the side of the stage we have a cyber
cyber Center any of these politicians or
the media if you got you're invited
yourself David if you want to come and
then then you can get your five million
dollar prize you can bring your own
cyber guys absolutely if you're beside
the stage you'll be able to punch in a
state or a county or the whole election
if you're punching the whole election
you got Donald Trump winning 80 million
to 68 million but now you do this now
listen we're going to have these hundred
cyber guys that came from all over the
country these are now none of them know
each other they were just they were they
were you know we invited and they
they've called in they prevented them
that they're the they're good they're
the best okay so they're going to divide
up into groups like let's say eight to a
group and we're gonna give them a state
here's the state of Georgia here's the
raw data and they're gonna sit there and
make sure a hundred percent that what
we're what I'm telling you is the truth
they'll go through it and they're going
to go through it I see they're gonna and
then we're gonna have them on the stage
and they're gonna have the people it's
like reading a language let's say let's
say this was all written in uh Chinese
you'd have to have people there that
could read the Chinese and say Yep this
is what it says now since it's
non-subjective every cyber guy will say
the exact same thing and when you're
watching that from home now when you're
watching that anybody's cyber guy or
anybody in the world that sees this will
be a hundred percent not 92 percent by
the time the Symposium is over everyone
Democrats Republicans liberals
conservatives are going to go well we
need to do something now this was an
attack by China this is real these
Heroes that captured this information
which is these packet couches our
government should have been doing this
because the Democrats weren't it but
yeah but you don't they said oh they're
not none of the machines were online so
why would you it'd be like getting flood
insurance when you say hey there's not
going to be any water but they lied to
you yeah they lied to the American
people so uh they're I'm I'm out of
breath from all of this information that
you're giving me Mike there's a couple
other things I want to get to and maybe
on the I know your time is short so
maybe we can keep these short I am not a
Christian so I may not be in a position
to understand this but if Donald Trump
was selected by God as you are certain
that he was why would God allow Joe
Biden to even become president and force
you to go through all of this why not
just put Trump in the white house again
well I believe I believe that that sub
that's part of this Divine Divine thing
that's going on because really people
don't look let me tell you people do not
look for Hope unless things are going
bad huh and this that's why I believe
this will be the greatest Revival for
Jesus and we will be once again one
nation under God ever because all these
people including yourself are going to
see Miracles unfold here Mike are you
saying even even even a Jewish guy like
me will see Jesus
okay
what's that even a Jewish guy like me
Miracles you're going to see Miracles
unfold you're going to see Miracles
unfold you can believe whatever you want
but you're going to see things that you
thought were impossible okay happen and
you're saying you asked me why would God
why would God let this happen yeah well
if you don't people don't look for I'll
give an example
um I was in a you know I was in about
two years ago I was a guy and he said
and he goes Mike our nation has turned
his back on God people have turned his
back on him and he says we would need
people aren't looking for God unless
things bad happening he said he goes if
something like the Great Depression I
said no no in the Great Depression they
had God they were just praying for food
and shelter I said we have something
better than that I said we have
addiction I said so this is when I set
up my lindo recovery Network done or I
said when you're an addiction you're
looking for hope you're looking out
there you need and it's about your soul
it's about salvation you're praying okay
but then Along Came the China virus the
pandemic and then came this election
ever everybody everybody is seeing what
is going on now I have Democrat friends
of mine and the liberal friends of mine
I talk to them they go wow I can't
believe this my
this my manifestation social I'm not
blaming the Democrat Party I'm saying
that the China picked them and they use
them and you're going to see this at the
Symposium I see so you're gonna see
these when people say well coming
straightening out our country I'll give
an example to David then when Jimmy
Kimmel said to me in his attack he said
Mike would you do it if it was reversed
I said of course this isn't about Donald
Trump I said this is about saving our
country with with China and these
machines this is about saving not just
our country but the world all these
other countries are worried too they got
we are in an age where it's cyber
attacks this is computers that can take
your country and and I said and you know
what happened after that they came back
the Washington Post and all these
Outlets came to Minnesota and asked my
friends and people from my past come on
would Mike really be sounding the alarm
if Donald Trump if they'd have picked
him trying to pick him every one of them
said yes David do you think they did a
story on that no every one of them
because you know what this is about our
country this is about elections I don't
it doesn't matter who won or lost it
it's it when your vote didn't matter and
you're going to see that at the Cyber
Symposium nobody's vote matter during
that nobody's vote matter they use the
2010 census report that's why you have
so many rural counties where double the
people voted that even live in the
county and this was all these are done
on a total separate thing or with
mathematics yeah that we could not
improve this Mike there's this
incredible image of you in the aftermath
of the election leaving the White House
and a zoomed in picture sees you
carrying a paper that says martial law
on it who raised the topic of Martial
law in that meeting with Trump
well let me see now if you'd have done
your due diligence on that David I said
I was bringing him the evidence I got on
January 9th this cyber evidence that I
got brought to me on January 9th okay
that was four pages these other lawyers
had given me two pages to give to him I
had never even read it I didn't know
what was on it that got opened up it
never got talked about in the Oval
Office that's a very famous story there
I brought in the evidence this is why
I'm asking you yeah yeah but he said
bring this upstairs the lawyers brought
me upstairs now the sheets were over
they gave me the sheets back and I was
outside the back end and then they seen
that martial law in there
um it was never brought up in the Oval
Office it was okay and he didn't and the
sheets were given back and I brought
upstairs to his attorneys which shoot me
out of the White House okay that's why
I'm asking to get the story straight
from you two other real quick you know
what yes but that was so important you
know why yeah because no no media would
talk to Mike Lindell so from that point
on every single day I was attacked by
bounce and trolls my retailers are gone
on my shopping channels they attacked
Mike Lindell my pillow Dominion sued
over 200 people and or and used law fear
in our country to where last week I just
had to dump Fox shame on Fox news I've
had to use all the left-wing media every
day they have my direct number I get
calls from morning tonight but you know
what they bash me and they attacked me
but at least I get to talk about the
truth which is trying to attacked our
country and stole our election from the
American people last two things one do
you have voting machines in your
possession somewhere
two yes we do you do and how many of
them
I don't know that I don't know that the
if they I have no idea we're bringing
we're going to have that snowing we're
going to have it the Cyber Symposium
we're going to show you my collections
we're going to have site random cyber
people put in a soundproof room we're
going to capture the packets which are
in the routers of course that's why
Arizona Won't Give Up the routers strong
routers yeah where did you get the
voting machines where did you get them
um there are no lawyers got them believe
me they were got legal you can buy them
on eBay there okay why don't you buy a
couple I don't have any use for them
quite frankly last thing Mike um Frank
speech it was billed as it will be the
new revolutionary social website when I
check it it's just like a video of you
talking what's going on with that no
that's Lindell TV that's correct you're
very incorrect if you go there there's
thousands of uh of uh these are all boys
the network part was built first so all
these people that have had their voices
suppressed yeah like your like your um I
don't know pick anyone that has been
kicked off a YouTuber Vimeo for talking
about machines or vaccines yeah or even
or even Jesus they've been kicked off of
there canceled out now they're over here
so we have a safe place where they know
they don't have their platform pulled
that's our Network part the social media
part is coming out probably in a month
or two oh okay and that that's the part
where people can go like the the Twitter
Department right now for me the the
media apartment and so we would have a
voice we have millions of people on
there now and so when I talk the words
getting out instead of people like Fox
that don't let the word out right so now
at least I have the terrible media that
bashes me every day and I'm able to talk
on my own platform and put out stuff
that doesn't get censored it's our First
Amendment right to free speech like Alan
dershowitz said well he's one of my
attorneys he said really you know Mike
this will be the most important case for
our first amendment right of free speech
in history because they only use law
fair one other time in 1798. well that's
where they use a lot there just suppress
so if you get you know it'll be amazing
if you know on your show if you can say
Dominion Dominion Dominion or smartmatic
smart manic you know Mike um I
appreciate your time so much are if if
this doesn't work out are you open to
the idea that maybe Joe Biden just won
or like are you even even theoretically
open to that David I put everything I
had on your going to watch it too so I
would really like it if you came and
brought a cyber guy and tried to win the
five million dollar prize wow I know in
the beginning here you kind of mocked it
I'll bet you 25 000. I know you don't
believe it you don't know people don't
that was serious I would bet you 25.
invite to the Symposium uh and you can
send your own be your own cyber guy win
the five million dollar prize you could
expand your audience
I'm traveling on that day one chance
there is 100 no chance that this didn't
happen because I'm showing evidence you
need to understand yeah it captures I
have it for the whole election I have it
in my possession it's like help me it's
like is this a phone yes it's a phone
that's why it's going to be a 9-0 vote
from the Supreme Court wow
asking him about anything that's
subjective this is the evidence it's
like it's like you and I taking a
picture in the 1970s where you couldn't
alter it right you know you can't alter
it you can't change it it shows
everything in detail yeah you have the
pack of captures it's like why in
Arizona did they want to give up the
routers because those show the packet
captures if you ask any cyber guy in the
world if you have a Cyber attack which
we have all the time on private
businesses uh the government everything
and we just had a Gaslight one these
cyber experts that I hire to validate
this evidence remember I've spent about
12 million 50 million dollars now of my
own money yeah validate all this
evidence so that I could sit here and
tell you I've already had the people the
best in the world look at it and they
said these are people that protect our
country and say this is 100 I said it's
not 99.9 they said no 100 I said well
when you when you have a Cyber attack or
breach
um is what's that you know do you need
more they said no if you have the packet
captions you you have it all Wow Mike
Lindell CEO and inventor of my pillow
Mike you've really said it all I we will
be watching we will be waiting for what
will happen over the next month or two I
really appreciate your time and telling
us your perspective today yeah if
everybody can get to I want the everyone
needs to watch this so you if you watch
frankspeach.com and you watch it during
any time during those 72 hours that's
all you're gonna need and you're gonna
be worried about I am about our country
are going to go David you'll be the
first one to call me I'll give you my
direct number you can go Mike what are
we going to do
I will be watching Mike appreciate it
thank you thank you David
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's cover a couple of other things in
the limited time we have left today uh
thanks to that uh wacky and long
interview with Mike pillow my my pillow
founder Mike Lindell we've been
wondering you know sort of like what is
going to happen depending on what does
or doesn't happen in August or September
of course there's going to be no
reinstatement of Donald Trump we are
starting to get some data points that
they are planning something and I have
one video to look at here with you today
this is
um a Maga or organizer named Matt
Brainerd affiliated with an organization
called look ahead America he was on with
Steve Bannon and seems to be saying that
September 18th is going to be a date on
which they are going back to the capitol
of course the capital being the place
where the Trump riots took place so
let's listen to that I'm actually going
to make some news on your show today we
have our next rally planned it's in the
middle of September September 18th and
it's going to be huge and what's going
to Define it is where it's going to take
place right we're going back to the
Capitol so understand
whether you consider this an overt or a
more sort of implicit signal about what
they're talking about he's saying we're
gonna redo January 6. now to what extent
it's going to be redone we don't yet
know right where it started on September
18th and we're going to push back
against the phony narrative that there
was an Insurrection we're going to
provide the kind of evidence that Nancy
Pelosi won't allow to be presented at
her select committee showing that this
was a largely peaceful crowd showing
that this was a crowd that was egged on
in many ways by Capitol Police throwing
flash flashbang grenades into a
relatively peaceful crowd relatively
peaceful is an interesting way to
describe it relative to what we're going
to present the evidence that Ashley
Babbitt's death should be investigated
we're going to demand now now remember
Ashley Babbitt's death was investigated
it was investigated we have a full
report about it police the 14 000 hours
of videotape that the the federal
government has been suppressing that's
another one of these where we we have
even even if you grant that not every
minute of video has been released
we already have hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours of video and
so the idea that only the video that's
being kept secret as they claim is what
would change our entire perception of
what took place that's another false
narrative that they're pushing so we're
going right back to the Capitol because
we're not afraid and we're going to
press our case and I believe that at
that we're going to have some very high
profile speakers there we're going to
have members of Congress speak we're
going to continue to raise the volume
and push back against this phony
narrative and demand Justice for these
political prisoners Justice for
political prisoners can you imagine so
if you check out
um the website for this organization
look ahead America they said they've
announced their next rally it's called
Justice for j6 if you can imagine
something more depraved and they say it
will be at the Capitol on September 18th
at noon so much reason to be worried and
hopefully this is something that law
enforcement is paying attention to we'll
talk about that a little bit more
tomorrow I received a video from a
concerned citizen one of our viewers in
Dothan I think it's pronounced Dothan
maybe Dothan Alabama
Marjorie Taylor green was in Alabama
about 10 days ago
at an event at which filming was not
allowed but our viewer this concerned
citizen surreptitiously filmed and in
this event sponsored by the Alabama
Federation of Republican women Marjorie
Taylor green was the keynote speaker she
suggests shooting vaccinators if indeed
people start coming door-to-door
offering vaccines this is a sitting
member of Congress this is video
provided exclusively to us take a look
at this take a listen to this and one
more thing on that you lucky people here
in Alabama might get a knock on your
door because I hear Alabama might be one
of the most unvaccinated states in the
nation
guys they're cheering for being
unvaccinated they're cheering for being
unvaccinated they're cheering because
they haven't been vaccinated
well Joe Biden wants to come talk to you
guys
he's going to be sending one of his
police state friends uh to your front
door we I call them nurses you know
police state friends I I would I would
call them nurses
door take down your name your address
your family members names your phone
numbers your cell phone numbers probably
ask for your social security number and
whether you've taken the vaccine or not
yeah well what they don't know is in the
South we all love our second amendment
rights
can you imagine
[Applause]
you're showing up on our front door
aren't we
we're big on our Second Amendment rights
and we're not big on Strangers showing
up at our front door this is a sitting
member of Congress joking about the idea
Joe I mean is it a joke I guess is the
question alluding to the idea of if
people come around offering vaccines to
keep us safe to reduce the chance that
we die
um guns would be what are deployed
against those individuals a sitting
member of Congress so thanks to our
viewer who is asked to remain anonymous
who filmed this surreptitiously again
that was July 23rd in Dothan Alabama
um it was an event actually
uh that Mo Brooks also was there Mo
Brooks is the guy who despite saying
that the January 6th Insurrection was no
big deal we found out he was wearing
body armor that day he also spoke at
this event and absolutely horrifying
spread the video far and wide we do want
to make sure as many people as possible
see that we have a voicemail number that
you can call that number is 2192 David P
here is again a caller continuing to
accuse me of suppressing the truth about
what it's not even clear I think he's
referring to kovid because that's what
he's always referring to
hey what's up David it's Eric from Mass
again he loved to make fun of my accent
how you doing man what I just wanted to
say uh with all the stuff coming out
that you're suppressing
um there's only two options here and
this is good
either you're too stupid to realize that
well you're in on it and buddy I would
never call you stupid
yeah you know one of the really I mean
there's a lot of sad stuff here
typically when this guy calls in he'll
refer to something like David you're
covering up that millions of people have
died from the vaccine or something like
that and it's like no I'm not covering
that up that's not real but there's this
other really weird thing that's being
lodged at people who just like report
the science about what's going on with
the virus and vaccines which is they
they suggest that you know why I by
saying I'm in on it what exactly would I
be in on what advantage would there be
to me like no you know no there's no
financial advantage to just telling the
truth about the vaccines there's no
personal Advantage other than yes it's
true if more people get vaccinated I'm
safer in people I know are safer part of
the conspiracy that assumes that you
know this idea of complicit in lying
about the vaccines and covid is that
there would be some Advantage conferred
by it and of course they can never
really explain what what that Advantage
is uh but no nothing has been covered up
and by the way when when uh some
upcoming show
increasingly people are pointing to the
vares system v-a-e-r-s and saying look
at all of these reports of people who
died from the vaccine in the vayers
system I'm thinking of doing a video
where I actually I'll show you on a
screen share I'll go through the vares
system and show you how easy it is to
just say my brother died from the
vaccine and submitted and of course it's
not check I wouldn't actually submit it
I would just show you how easy it would
be to do this is what people are doing
people are submitting bogus reports to
the vares system and then those bogus
reports are being used by anti-vaccine
individuals and media outlets and
pointed to and said look at all of these
reports anybody can submit a report
there's no checking whatsoever that is
done on the bonus show today we will
talk about you remember that Missouri
couple of lawyers who were waving guns
last June during the black lives matter
protest
they both pleaded guilty to misdemeanors
they've been pardoned by the Missouri
governor yeah the mccloskeys we'll talk
about that on the bonus show secondly we
appear to be between
two and five weeks away from FDA full
approval of the coronavirus vaccine uh
made by Pfizer will this really get some
of these anti-vaxxers vaccinated I don't
know we're going to talk about it and
lastly the Japanese government is
starting a program of publicly naming
people who are breaking quarantine rules
in Japan is this a good idea could it
lead to disaster what would happen if
the United States did it all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up and get instant access by uh
making yourself a member at
joinpakman.com I'll speak to you then
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpackman